[Música]
que hoje vai falar de um assunto que na
minha opinião é crucial que a
participação dos jovens na sociedade
mas primeiro eu gostava de contar o
episódio pelo qual passava o ano passado
foi minha primeira aula que os fiéis
nessa aula nós fizemos uma ficha de
avaliação diagnóstica que tinha um
exercício de verdade falso e exercício
tinha duas afirmações com deixaram mais
pensativo é a primeira reconhecia que
todas as crianças têm capacidade de
enfrentar e por ser um móvel responde
imediatamente que era verdadeiro
essas crianças são extremamente curiosa
a gente só vê sem saber mais
no entanto a segunda afirmação que
reconhecia que a generalidade das
pessoas não têm esse mesmo espanto
perante a vida é simples e realmente a
pensar será que esta curiosidade o
presente no ccb se mantém ao longo de
nossas vidas
eu tive que ir à parte da minha pessoa
que ainda acredita em humanidade ainda
tem esperança que nós cheios que nunca
deixamos de nos tentar superar e que
aprendemos com os nossos erros mas
segundo a convenção que foi fornecida a
afirmação é falsa
eu sei que lá no fundo sabe a resposta
até porque estou a passar por uma
experiência a nível académico bastante
semelhantes como a áfrica onde os alunos
entram pra primária tendência bastante
participativos e sete voos
eu tenho esta imagem dos alunos quando
entrou para a escola sempre continuar a
fazer e responder a perguntas e posso
confirmar o fust infelizmente diz que
esse cenário não se mexe em time até que
o contrário tende a agravar-se que
entraram agora expõe tenha sido um pouco
ingênuo ao pensar que este país se
mantém ao longo ao longo de nossas vidas
por exemplo quando é feita uma pergunta
nos níveis superiores de ensino é pouco
freqüente ser o aluno pedir para
responder e então tem que ser o
suficiente para ganhar fazer quando
sentem que as suas idéias não estão a
ser valorizado ante vão deixar de
utilizar e ainda pior
vão passar a confirmar os cookies e dito
sem espanto e segmento com uma rapariga
de 16 anos conhecendo que alguma coisa a
dizer
a opinião é da área
estamos a fazer eu vi minha vó ser
respeitada e menos utilizada uma grande
quantidade de vezes ao longo da minha
vida
por ter esse cuidado muito cedo tive na
minha capacidade argumentativa
isso é que o mesmo acontece com muitos
jovens quando nós temos alguma coisa de
gerar cerca de um tópico é a geração
mais velha
questiona se frequentemente como
queremos saber se nós choramos tornou
cheney não vivemos no mundo real e
crachá se ainda não temos a
responsabilidade de ter um carro causa
dividir pegar outra criança inspira
cuidados
então nós não sabemos nada sobre a vida
nem sobre o mundial
em nossa opinião nunca passará de uma
mera especulação
essa idéia está tão enraizada na nossa
sociedade os criminosos de opiniões de
jovens tocam as minhas são ignorados e
de organizadas todos os dias
e o pior é que isso acontece muitas
vezes porque sua inscrição próximas como
os nossos familiares nossos amigos e é
isso que nós temos de alterar não só
está em 200 em casa pois a docência faz
mais antitética de vida onde tudo é um
constante lima acredita em seu site
por um lado do centro exige cada vez
mais liberdade cada vez mais
independência mas por outro enfim
estamos constantemente apoio da
aprovação e sim nós precisamos da
aprovação
muitos não querem admitir mas nesta fase
da vida é ter vindo dizer filosófica
onde esperamos com questões existenciais
conflitos tv tentando simultaneamente
descobrir a nossa verdadeira identidade
nós corremos os adultos com mais de
obter aprovação perceber se o que nós
dizemos nós pensamos é efetivamente
correto ou não
então construir exame o que sente um
show pode ser bastante complicado para
alguns nós e somos ignorados por aqui os
cursos blaz estancianos nós começamos
aos poucos e duvidar das nossas próprias
capacidades
será que eu devia ter uma opinião sobre
o conflito entre israel e palestina
eu só tem 16 anos não via história
pensar sobre a moralidade 8 e 9 e será
que eu consigo lutar contra a
desigualdade gênio ou que minha voz
consegue fazer a mudança
quando eu me dei conta deste meus
pensamentos concluir que esta de
valorização da opinião do jovem
é bastante errada e também um problema
com uma dimensão que nem eu tinha
previsto
eu que acredito na opinião de que irá
nascer a gestores de entendimentos sua
cultura da sua religião nas sociedades
do seu génio eu duvidaria e ainda devido
algumas das linhas da ash é apenas
porque não vieram de um adulto
eu penso que esse problema ainda não é
integrado por virar se dado exatamente
porque não houve uma tomada de
consciência acerca desse tópico e por
onde para humanos lev falta de
reconhecimento
será que nós já pensamos neste impacto
em nível local é eu acredito pelo menos
brasília nas minhas deficiências e nem
dos meus pais
muita gente não pensou neste assunto
como obstáculo ao desenvolvimento
pessoal de cada indivíduo mas também
social econômico e político qualquer com
isso na minha opinião uma dessas
consequências tem o nome de brinde e o
fuga de cérebros em português e este
filme consiste na migração de
profissionais que vão para o display
país procurar melhores condições
laborais
mas ao contrário da emigração nos anos
60 para a frança em que os portugueses
eram maioritariamente por qualificado
é realmente um sonho português bastante
qualificado e jovens muitas vezes com os
seus títulos de mestrado foi nosso peixe
procuram melhores condições laborais no
desperdício
sobre este assunto foi feito um estudo
chamado fuga de cérebros chambily
daquele emigração portuguesa quanto com
1.011 entrevistas o português já viver
nestas condições é este estudo mostrou
que 52 por cento dos portugueses
consideravam ser pouco ou nada provava
passarem ao seu país de origem e com
eles foram perguntados as razões da sua
direcção
grande parte ponto é procura de um
melhor emprego de um melhor salário mas
também em cidade progressão na carreira
e realização pessoal é ou seja não era
só sobre encontrar um emprego como eu
tinha um emprego certo sim em portugal
46% dos jovens não estavam desempenhar
funções em áreas compatíveis com os seus
estudos no estrangeiro este valor é
significativo é significativamente mais
baixo onda os 25%
é eu posso concluir com isto é que é
postar em ver suas aptidões o seu
trabalho ser valorizado no plano
financeiro grande parte não é desejo é
voltar ao seu país de origem por vezes
não é o jovem que 84 o trabalho mas sim
o trabalho não é de quatro jovens que
exige a progressão na carreira e ele se
da realização pessoal
apenas nesta direção vai ter
repercussões a nível gráfico claro mas
também a nível social o nível econômico
e clique qualquer país visto que os
jovens são mais criativos e dinâmicos e
sem ter um modo algum em finalizar o
alfeneiro direção mais velha mas a
verdade é que os jovens tendem a pensar
de uma maneira menos convencional de
mais inovador é muitas vezes por causa
da sua abertura de espírito mas também
viveu aquele espanto é o que
anteriormente falava quem lhe resta é eu
faço parte de um projeto chamado jovens
impulsionador dos direitos humanos de
igualdade por um vivo pela cooperativa
saini cidade e por causa dos projetos
envolve aptidões sociais como a
participação o envolvimento o trabalho
em equipa e convive com jovens tal como
eu tenho um bichinho dentro deus que não
se deixa confirmar se com alguns dogmas
criticou a cut diz que os faz lutar por
causas mais de um estande visando sempre
uma vida melhor em sociedade e posso
dizer que é bom sentir que nós não somos
os únicos de frente em que somos os
únicos que se preocupa
segundo a organização das nações unidas
a participação é um direito fundamental
em diante a participação ativa o jovem
empoderado para desempenhar um papel
fundamental no seu próprio
desenvolvimento bem como desenvolvimento
sua sociedade
eu espero que nós possamos participar
têm enxergado os instrumentos adequados
nós temos que ter essa oportunidade e
ágil desde que me lembro eu sempre tive
o desejo de fazer parte de algo maior do
que eu eu sempre tive muitas opiniões
idéias radicais e também uma ambição e
vento mudar e melhorar
no entanto não sabia o que fazer não
sabia qual era a utilidade e o poder de
exigir a existir fazer parte deste
projeto
infelizmente hoje em dia os valores
shift e políticos não são devidamente
abordados neste
aulas visto que é abordagem científicas
teóricas e factuais são as mais
utilizadas
contudo ao longo deste 11 a titularidade
eu tiver sorte a oportunidade de ter
professores que não se preocupavam
apenas com o nosso sucesso com as nossas
notas mas também com a nossa formação
enquanto cidadãos o que é ainda mais
louvável na minha opinião mas agora
imaginem imagina a quantidade de jovens
que estão a passar pelo mesmo
imagine a quantidade de jovens que tal
como aconteceria comigo tem seu espírito
de vitória inesquecível espera de ajuda
para libertar mas pediu incentivos ou
gangues mostra que não estão sozinhos
não são diferentes que não se devem
confirmar que devem participar e que
acima de tudo devem mostrar e fazer é
sua voz ouvida no entanto ao contrário
do que aconteceu comigo é muito não
chegou em contrário está o incentivo
muitos não chegam encontrar em aceitar a
oportunidade e não é revoltante não é
chocante saber que todos os dias tanto
potencial é desperdiçado
conseqüentemente eu gostava de destacar
a importância de associações e
cooperativas que envolvem os jovens a
assistir ao com um projeto como este mas
também é roubar esse é dos nossos
filiados pois nossos amigos dos nossos
professores que podem e devem estimular
as gerações mais novas
na minha cabeça eu tenho uma certa
imagem como seria se o jovem aprendesse
cozido ti e vice versa porque é
suposição de que nós somos os únicos a
anunciar com sabedoria dos mais velhos é
bastante errada
se houvesse uma colaboração entre estas
duas direções
talvez hoje nós não tivéssemos durante
um pouco mais aquela capacidade de
cantar o refrão de vida o que era uma
mais valia
por isso e para concluir eu gostaria de
fazer um apelo aos jovens para que hoje
acredita em utilizem o seu voz sem ter
medo nem o site
eu vejo que me ouvem falar em com jovens
da vossa família é do círculo de amigos
e da vossa comunidade facilmente
perguntas sobre injustiças e
desigualdades sociais
discutam políticas e problemas
ambientais e mais importante ou são
jovens
claro nós não vamos aprender tudo uma
vez não vamos mexer
tenham paciência conosco mostra em que
nossas opiniões merecem ser ouvidas que
nossas vidas são suficientemente boa
acho que nós conseguimos fazer
influência no mundo porque os jovens não
são apenas o futuro da sociedade
achamos também o presente obrigada
[Aplausos]